all right we are here for another ask me
anything session and that's exactly what
we're going to do those who ask
questions will hopefully get answers you
want to get them in early on because
they will pile up fairly quickly as
viewers come in and start asking things
so for the first hour I will take
questions more or less in the order that
they're being posted and then maybe the
last half an hour so I will probably be
taking questions there we go put a
little more light on taking questions in
order of interest I won't get to
everything but we never do we do these
once a month for those who want to know
how they can get in on it and you can
always find when these are going to
happen post it in the reason IO events
calendar that's my company's website
reason IO calm or you can find it in my
facebook author page under events so
while people are lining up questions
I'll say just a little bit about what's
been going on this last month you know
it was international stoic week we had a
stoic on X event here in Milwaukee that
went quite well and we also had you know
stoic on X events all over the world I
participated in remotely in the stoic on
X Brisbane event I did a video for them
which you may have seen in the channel
and then did a Q&A by Skype all right so
we've already got a question here hey
there dr. Sadler why are booked one in
two of Aristotle's metaphysics so hard
well because it's metaphysics it's not
it's not going to be easy and I'm trying
to
get things lined up here so I can get a
bit more stability Hill it strapped like
this that's much better
you should you know there's there's
really two things going on or maybe
three things one is the first thing is
that Aristotle is trying to engage with
all of his predecessors and that is
quite a doing any any time that you're
doing a history of philosophy you're
going to be doing it in terms of the
concepts that you're most interested in
right and so Aristotle is thinking in
terms of the causes that he is putting
forth as is really a new innovation on
his own part and he's rereading what's
available in the history of philosophy
in that way through that lens you could
say there's also the fact that Aristotle
is is writing in a technical language
which is often the case for metaphysics
I'm going to see if I can move this
chord a little bit help me out so you
know any time that you've got a
technical language it's going to be a
bit trickier there's concepts that have
to be learned you have to understand the
relationship of the words to each other
there is also the danger when we're
looking at english translations or you
know whatever other language you're
reading it in of taking the terms in a
way that's that's quite different than
what were normally used to and this
doesn't just hold for Aristotle this
holds for all these other thinkers that
we might read as well and then you know
metaphysics is inherently difficult so
anybody who claims that they can make it
easy as bullshitting you and you should
probably ignore them any you know a lot
of those like channels and books that
claim to make everything simple they're
really selling you the philosophical
snake-oil and you know epistemology is
difficult to and even ethics is
difficulty
bears on you know practical everyday
things when you're doing real ethics
it's quite quite tricky alright let's
take the next one Martin Heidegger
defined philosophy as the science of
being what do you think that means well
I think it means what the Heidegger
means what Heidegger says so you know he
has this notion of being capital B and
beings lowercase B and the totality of
beings and he's not coming up with that
idea by himself you know metaphysics
Aristotle says is the science of being
qua being Heidegger happens to think
that metaphysics is indeed is Aristotle
thought first philosophy and so it's you
know it's an investigation into the
different modalities and types of beings
and trying to understand capital B being
so you know that's pretty
straightforward here's a question from
chef Ali Khan what books would you
recommend for beginners and stoicism I
always recommend primary texts I mean
again you can you can choose like you
know stoicism made easy or stoicism for
dummies or any of that sort of stuff if
you want to but you don't know whether
you're actually being led astray or not
you should read Epictetus you should
read Marcus Aurelius you should read
Seneca they're readily available on the
net you know you should probably start
if you want like short texts read one of
you know Senecas shorter texts and
couple that with epictetus is
enchiridion and then read you know
Aurelius is meditations and then you'll
want to go back and read the longer
texts like Senecas you know full letters
to Luke Ilyas also sometimes called
Senecas moral of pistols there's a lot
of different you know translations and
additions out there and you want to read
Epictetus discourses and then you want
to go further and reading other things
but those will get you started all right
um
I already have a lot of questions so I'm
going to scroll back up mark s on human
nature do you believe that it's
unchangeable over time or is its
contingent upon the society and time
period neither I think that human nature
is incredibly complex and it's also
somewhat open-ended but I don't believe
that it's because of that merely
contingent on the society and time
period I think there's some constants
but that very often what we take to be
like total constants turn out to have
some contingency to them and we I you
know I would say that it's not that the
ordinary person or even the
Intelligencia of this time necessarily
understands human nature better than
they did say in the early modern period
or the high middle ages or you know in
antiquity there's some things that are
better some things that are worse I
would say actually our modern psychology
is for the most part more than sort of
looking the average level not as not as
intelligent about say emotions and their
relationship to our thoughts with
exceptions as some ancient philosophers
were but and all that has to do with
human nature you know I would say that
that we you know human nature is humans
is something that humans realized by
reflecting on themselves the societies
that they lived in what they take to be
constants from the information that they
had and we never have enough information
and it's sort of you know it is a
construct right but it's a construct
that does correspond to something out
there but it's so incredibly malleable
and open-ended because you know we are
the creature that has much fewer
instincts there's one reason why I think
evolutionary biology and psychology for
the most part is is wishful thinking or
you know people kind of bullshitting
around and oversimplifying again with
that with exceptions we don't you know
we're not like all the other animal
once you start introducing culture into
the mix it gets incredibly more
complicated right so there we go um
William asks I've been getting into John
Dewey and Richard Rorty well that's what
you were going to spend your time on can
you help me understand what Richard
Rorty means my truth is a product of
conversation key points I should know
about pragmatism
yeah key points a you should know about
pragmatism it's better to read James and
purse and Royce than spend your time and
work into it I would say do we do he's
interesting I mean I got so much Dewey
when I was at Southern Illinois and and
so much of it from people who thought
that he was basically like the savior
you know it's like they were they were
almost like a cult of durians out there
I was never that impressed with Dewey
didn't particularly care for his writing
and when Rory came out and started
saying things you know based on his sort
of bringing together Dewey and Vidkun
shine and Heidegger I you know my my
response was so what yeah we can't
realize this stuff so you know truth is
a product of a conversation what does
that mean it means that that in part
I mean he's not saying that all truth is
a product of a conversation right and
and you know pragmatists even though
they have like a pragmatic theory of
truth it's not that they think that the
correspondence theory of truth is just
totally off-base there are some things
like you know whether coffee is in this
cup or not that could be true or false
based on how things are right but there
are quite a few things that are where
truth is a product of conversation and
Rory isn't the first person to notice
that I mean we if we use different
terminology we could say hey you'll
notice that the whole dialectical
movement noticed that but you know I
mean pragmatism it usually works best
when it's not just taken on its own I
would
when it's tied together with with some
other platform and that's that's part of
what I like about say James and
particularly Royce
all right Shefali Ken what do you think
about the Ship of Theseus there's not
much to think it's an interesting
problem I make reference to it in
classes Laura awesome Tony I'm reading
Russell's the history of western
philosophies this is a good foundation
good if you want to be off-base on
things I mean I wouldn't rely on
Russell's take on the history of
philosophy any more than I would on an
Rand or you know somebody was just
writing me today about Gibbon and
whether you know they should they should
keep reading given or read Eckhart and I
was like holy crap you know because
what's given known for his history of
the fall the Roman Empire which is you
know it's a nice story but not true in
many respects and things can be false
and in you know by the emphases by the
you know conclusions draw in all sorts
of ways don't rely on Russell for
history I mean he's popular but I mean
if you want somebody from his time who's
looked at as a fairly good source that's
relied on in graduate school for history
philosophy Friedrich cobblestone you
know at least cobblestone isn't kind of
steer you wrong about stuff because of
his own biases or failures to comprehend
what was going on and in somebody's
thought I'm always surprised that
Russell still has so much weight these
days all right
McClatchy has a question about Conte and
the third critique how exactly councils
the antenna me had taste how to direct
dare derive that from the analytic of
the beauty I don't remember it's been a
while since I've looked at the third
critique so I wouldn't venture to try to
do that ah here's one a good a good one
from solstice or maybe that's not how
it's pronounced what should I read after
Hegel's phenomenology of spirit also
what are important contemporary major
philosophical problems and any major
philosopher who's dealing with
these major problems today so I'm going
to answer the first one and I'll briefly
answer the second one what should you
read after Hegel's phenomenology of
spirit you've worked your way through
the whole thing
I mean I'm tempted to joke and say
reread it cuz first reading you you
missed probably 90% of what was going on
in the text and spent a lot of time
saying what the hell is this crap right
but you know I would Hegel so here's
what here's Hegel's answer after you
finish the phenomenology of spirit
obviously you have to go on to the
science of logic but maybe maybe don't
do that maybe save that for a little bit
later on you know I usually don't
suggest that people begin with the
phenomenology of spirit there's two
other texts that I think are pretty good
for getting into Hegel's ideas before
you do that and there they're almost you
know mirror opposites of each other in a
way there's the lectures on the history
of philosophy and the lectures on the
philosophy of history those are much
more accessible than the phenomenology
and I think they'll you know they cover
some of the same ground in parts but
they'll give you a nice idea about how
Hegel sees things and how the dialectic
advances and all of that sort of stuff
I actually like his you know I like
reading his other lectures I used to do
a lot of work on the lectures on the
philosophy of religion back in the day
and you know he goes sort of like like
Heidegger in that there's a big corpus
of lectures from class stuff and you
know these were lectures he was
providing to undergraduates I think for
the most part but they're pretty
advanced stuff you know so there's some
real meat there you could go on to the
science of logic I mean you could always
read the Encyclopedia logic if you want
that's that's quite a bit easier and
you're gonna find it covering some of
the same ground and then there's the
philosophy of right which is definitely
worth reading so there's a lot of stuff
you could you could check out all right
just just jumped a little bit let's see
what we got next in the order Gabriel I
wanted to ask you if you could explain
the concept of Acadia and who I should
be reading so yeah this is a a thing
that's often referenced in the monastic
literature and it's part of the the sort
of conceptual apparatus of what what
comes later to be called the seven
deadly sins
after Gregory the Great's moralia and
robe the Gregory by the way who I was
named after and prior to that it's
understood as one of the eight capital
vices or one of the eight bad thoughts
depending on whether you're reading John
Cassian or Evagrius of Pontus right so
acadia gets rolled into along with
Trista TIA or is it is it Lupe I think
in the Greek yeah I think it's Lupe gets
rolled into what we call sloth right and
sloth has always been kind of a
catch-all thing people think of it as
equivalent just to laziness but it's not
just laziness there's a kind of
distracted miss there and the inability
to focus in on one's own work and the
way that like John Cassian who has a
really great chapter on Acadia in his
Institute's
talks about it he uses the example of
the monk who instead of like sitting in
his his cell where he's supposed to be
and focusing on his work he's like you
know I should probably go check on
brother John you know he could use my
help over there
and he's like totally bullshitting
himself brother John doesn't need his
help he's just like going to find out
what what's going on over there because
he doesn't want to buckle down and focus
on his own his own business sometimes
it's called the noonday devil right
meaning it's it's the thing that
oppresses us think about it you know
like it when you're in your workplace
and you've done some of your work but
you're like I need to take a break maybe
I'll just like you know check social
media for a bit and then like half an
hour's past that that's a prime example
of it right I think that that social
media and the Internet in general I mean
think about going when you go down a
Wikipedia rabbit hole in like two hours
have passed you got nothing done you
were doing research right those are
those can be expressions of Acadia and
when it's a vice it really keeps you
from being able to get things done we
can all fall into that but we need to
like be able to bring ourselves back
through diligence and attentiveness to
to what it is that that needs to be done
so what should you be reading John
Cassian and Evagrius of Pontus or the
classic places to start I would say I'm
sure there's plenty of contemporary
literature I would hear on it but I
don't know Oh going back to the souks
this is a question any major philosopher
dealing with major problems today yeah
there's tons of them out there you know
I had talked about Alistair McIntyre all
the time is still alive and kicking and
dealing with major problems in
philosophy mostly in terms of ethics but
also politics and epistemology and other
things like that there's all these great
historians of philosophy who are you
know sort of recuperating ancient
thought or modern medieval thought or
even early modern thought and bringing
it to life and I'm a big fan of say
Julia honest or Christopher Gill you
know as examples of that a long is still
still around and still doing good work
John Sellars you know Margaret graver
people like that lots of people out
there doing doing good work
so all right while Josh asks do I know
any of the academics at university Essex
I don't most places you can probably say
the same thing
Antigua are you a fan of some of Toni
Morrison's books no as a matter of fact
I don't think I've ever read any Toni
Morrison book when it comes to
contemporary literature outside of
philosophy and even in philosophy I'm
not I'm not very well-read and you know
things that are things that happen into
my hands I'd I'll tend to read them but
I don't get a lot of time for reading
other things Jay - Nick do you think
Plato's dialogue karma day shows that he
was for pederasty I feel ya know I think
he was I think he was using the dialogue
if you read the dialogue to talk
primarily about the question of
temperance so and what would it would be
but there's always people that are more
focused on the the sexual aspects of the
dialogues I suppose than others boy do
you believe in a freedom of will yeah
but I mean that doesn't really mean that
much since there's so many different
understandings of what freedom of the
will would mean to people out there
right there so you always have to
clarify it Mason ever read Thomas Merton
yeah of course I read him as an
undergraduate I was quite interested in
comparative religions and you know
monasticism in general and so I read
Merton and and did my like you know
getting into him thing and then you know
found him as I found many of the people
I think of his sort of long generation
because remember Merton was was actually
not a young college student in the 60s
but he was one of the people that they
were reading I just found him and people
like Watts and all that to be
interesting at first and then just kind
of superficial after a while you know
there didn't seem to be that much meat
there
but I'm not attracted to mysticism so
all right Julia your justice justice
Shepard do you think the really old
figures in philosophy like Diogenes were
real people
it always feels like there's a bit of
mythology the further back you go in the
history of philosophy yeah of course
they're real people I mean there's even
people who like doubt did Socrates exist
you know I mean you can find people who
think Julius Caesar didn't exist but
that's so far out on the fringe that
he's exist it'd be nice if we had more
you know texts talking about him but I
don't know I don't know any serious
scholars who think that he didn't and
mythology it really depends on what you
mean by mythology you know you're
talking about like people like Zeus or
or you know Apollo and all that I guess
if you if you have a sort of viewpoint
that was actually taught talked about in
ancient times that wow these were just
human beings were then deified but
Diogenes wasn't de fide he was looked at
as the second leader or some in some
cases some people think he was the
actual first leader of the cynics cool
why believe he didn't exist HT ahd what
do I think about the cyclical view of
history versus the progressive Hegelian
one well I think the progressive
Hegelian one although false is probably
closer to the truth in a cyclical view
of history I mean how would you how
would you actually go about proving a
cyclical view of history if it's not all
that cyclical then it's not really
cyclical so if the things don't match up
perfectly why why even talk about it as
a cyclical view of history and if they
do match up perfectly somehow we'd have
like you know the eternal recurrence are
the same I suppose so
you know
the other thing to to keep in mind is
whenever we're doing historical
analogies we have to be able to say if
we want to say well this is just like
what happened back then and we ignore
all the other relevant ways in which
it's not the same we have to figure out
well which thing is it actually like so
a lot of people love and I've talked
about this before to say oh you know
what's going on in American culture just
like the follow the Roman Empire you
know and you know if you know much about
Roman history you'd be like yeah not
really like that what would be better
analogies I've mentioned this again in
AMAs many times the closest analogy that
I see to where we are historically is
what's laid out in William shires the
decline and fall of the French Third
Republic read that if you want to
understand where we're headed
that's probably they look the closer
analogy it's not gonna be ancient Rome
or things you know way the hell off like
that I mean what was going on in France
at that time totally deadlocked
political system unable to respond to
massive inequalities and you know clear
economic rot within cronyism generals
who were basically hamstrung by civilian
leaders and unable to oppose the threat
when it came or sometimes to Craven to
deal with it
way over extended military budgets and
alliances and things like that we forget
you know it's really funny that the
people are like you know the French or
surrender monkeys man if you were around
in in 1939 you you wouldn't view things
that way you know France had developed
an entire network of alliances Heming in
Germany for you know several decades and
they you know Bladon lost a lot of their
manpower in the First World War but they
also were able to still feel the pretty
sizable army and they had more tanks
than the Germans they were just weren't
being used effectively you know
if you want to make historical analogies
using a cyclical view of history you got
to really know a lot of history in order
to be able to do that I think all right
Frey length why do your Twitter post
seem on stoic like when discussing
politics because I don't claim to be a
stoic I mean if you think it you know if
this is so funny because there's two
things going on first off you probably
don't know what real stoicism is if you
think that opposing rot corruption you
know that sort of thing is understood
because you clearly don't know anything
about Cato or you know the the Stoics
who opposed Nero or anything like that
but I don't claim to be a stoic and if
you think that I do you obviously don't
know much about me or my background
people always this is gonna be a
sidenote rant people always like think
that they know so much about me by like
you know finding out one thing oh he's
the Hegel guy he must be a Hegelian not
a hey gal you just happen to do the half
hour Hegel project cuz nobody else was I
added stoicism today at one point I
worked for a Marxist institution I'm not
a Marxist right I've been a fellow
traveler on many accounts and I can do
that because when I see you know
institutions and movements that are
actually doing something worthwhile I'm
willing to collaborate with them also
when I see [ __ ] and evil and willing
to call it out as it is so you know the
other thing I'll say - about stoicism is
that although I don't call myself too
stoic because I'm not you know just
committed to to stoicism and I'm gonna
Ciceronian eclectic who uses stoicism
we're still ian is employed nism
existentialist thought you know brings
all these things together I probably
know more and practice more stoicism
than most of the people out there self
identifying in the present as Stoics so
those are all from some useful I think
answers for that
Cramer's ask the question a lot of
people ask thoughts on Carl Jung
interesting writer I think that as
psychology is
you know false I don't believe in
archetypes for anything like that
most of the young'uns who I've met have
been pretty nutty you know he's the sort
of person again talking about a
collectivism he's a sort of person that
I think it's useful to draw insights
from but they better be insights that
you can actually tie into more than
unionism or a land and more than just
New Age nonsense or else you're kind of
wasting your tongue and playing around
with you know wishful thinking stuff you
know wouldn't it be nice if the world
was like this and there were these deep
down archetypes and all that sort of
stuff so yeah you know Young is a fun
writer to read column core if you read
off Austin's sense and sensibility with
stick theory do you like to read yeah I
read Austin way back in graduate school
I haven't read him sense how much
linguistic Theory do I like to read I
like to read it when I can get to it but
most of it is not analytic philosophy
stuff that the analytic philosopher who
I like most to read is John wisdom
I teach Vidkun Stein in my classes
occasionally you know I some of those
earlier writers are fun to check out I
don't read much a contemporary analytic
philosophy because I find most of the
stuff that I've read and been
recommended to be so jargon heavy and
you know we're only going to talk about
what what these few writers over here
done and so you know unbaked and in the
history of thought that it's just not
worth my my spare time to do it that
said there's a lot of great philosophy
of language outside of analytic
philosophy I'm a huge fan of Umberto
eCos semiotics you know I also really
like kyle Pearlman's new rhetoric can't
even pronounce his collaborator old
Brexton ich that or something like that
that's an amazing book right and of
course if you're studying Heidegger
studying Agel and studying Aristotle
you're studying even ants um there's all
this brilliant discussion about language
in these peoples so yeah I guess I'd you
like to read a lot of linguistic Theory
Gabriel reading the science of logic and
I think after reading over and over I
understand the general development
that's good but I have a lot of trouble
exemplifying or thinking concretely what
I read well that's that's okay I think
the science of logic is harder than of
knowledge II that's my experience with
it I can't say that I have been able to
successfully apply much of what I've
read in there myself so I just stick
with it a revisionist show you appeared
on zero books a leftist podcast
interview with Douglas Lane would you
say that you identify with the political
left if so what are the reasons why you
identify with the left you could
probably ask that question about the
rightest podcasts and things that I've
appeared on too right
so it's funny that you in on zero zero
books on the left I'm a virtue ethicists
so that means that I'm not comfortable
on the right or the left and that I
think that probably 90% of the people
who identify with you they're just full
of crap and actually probably bad in
many respects and that would be similar
to what Aristotle says about people in
his own time you know in Aristotle's
time he framed it in terms of the poor
and the the many and he said they're
both full of crap
they both think that they they have you
know the interpretation of justice and
it just so happens to be one that favors
them and their interests and the ADI
story the people who are actually best
equipped to rule are the ones who are
least likely to engage in social status
or faction in order to try to try to
grab power well these other you know
smocks on left and right or you know
whatever arrangement we want to have
they're perfectly fine to undermine
everything right now i think the right
poses more
of a threat that hasn't always been the
case for me in the past I've been more
disenchanted with the left but right now
especially with the rise of Trump ISM
and what I see as actual you know
tendencies towards fascism in his regime
and in others as well as you know here
in Wisconsin the just absolute Craven
as' and you know Griff teenis of the
Republicans who have been running this
state for a while and and you know most
of what's going wrong in this state is
due to them I'm willing to line up with
them I'm a registered independent but
I'll be most likely voting straight
Democrat this this coming election and I
will definitely be voting against Ron
Johnson when he comes up for election in
2022 and so you know if you want to see
that is lining up with the left you can
for me it's always a matter of who's the
biggest threat who's the the ones who
are most damaging the the common good
and right now it's the right and the
Republicans so not to say that there
aren't you know plenty of nonsense
things going on on the left but we only
have so much time so I'm more willing to
devote it to discussing where the right
is going wrong right now but if you know
anything about me you know that in the
past I've been you know equally critical
of the left so alright JD r93 what do
you think about people using philosophy
in the corporate world for purely
utilitarian purposes they were purely
utilitarian they would be doing
something very different than the rest
of the corporate world because pure
utilitarians like Bentham or mill or
sidwich or even singer are genuine
genuine ly going to be generally going
to be opposed to the sort of things that
go out in corporations so what you
probably mean is sort of like reductive
you know things instrumental alright
what do I think about people using
philosophy in the corporate world for
purely instrumental purposes
um let them I mean that's how I actually
sometimes smuggle in some good
philosophy what I'm doing work with
corporate clients I don't tell them that
it's coming the stuff that I'm doing is
coming from Stoics or Aristotle or
Thomas Aquinas until they ask you know
and then I say yeah this
anger-management stuff came from these
other thinkers and it can make your
organization work better but if you want
it to work better you actually have to
start thinking in terms of virtue ethics
so I don't think that that you you can
really use philosophy in any substantive
way just for purely instrumental
purposes it winds up being a gateway
drug to better things now if you mean
like you know watered-down stuff like
what's going on with a lot of stoic
things today where people are doing
coaching or you know they have their
program that you can buy or something
like that then it's not really the
philosophy right it's just sort of a
sort of a residue of you know whatever
they've happened to study and there's
plenty of hucksters out there doing that
what do you get you know what am I gonna
do about that not much but you know that
sort of stuff doesn't really survive
that long it doesn't have much staying
power they end up just saying the same
things over and over again and when they
run into genuine problems they can't
really deal with them and that's when
people come to people like me and
they're like hey I tried working with
this and it gave me a nice introduction
but I don't know what to do after this
and I'm like well okay now we're ready
to really study art so then you know
that's what I think about it Shefali
Khan do you think Machiavellianism is a
moral philosophy and practical for
rulers I don't know if depends on what
you mean by machiavellianism if you mean
just like you know little Maxim's like
it's better to be feared than to be
loved or stuff like that then probably
not I mean well it's a moral philosophy
in the sense that it's saying that that
some things are better than others
you know it's not a good moral
philosophy or an adequate one I mean the
real Machiavelli thinks that the rich
and the powerful are budget
you know evils he says so right in the
prince if you actually read the text and
he says that they will inevitably try to
oppress the poor in the many and that
the poor and the many will try to you
know revolt against them and he says
don't be like one of them so the people
who are like Machiavelli tells me I
should be ruthless and you know exploit
people he says if you're gonna do that
you better be really really prudent
about it not look like it like a jerk
because when the when the people revolt
against you and won't work for you and
somebody else gobbles you up it's your
own damn fault
so yeah I'm sure here oh you once said
that Camus was hostile towards
Christianity exactly how intense was his
hostility depends on the work you know
he was hostile towards what he
understood is the Christianity of his
time he I mean he thinks that it's
essentially a cop-out he also knew
plenty of people in his own time and
there's plenty of them now who were
hypocrites and used Christianity as a
way of controlling people or not to deal
with their own BS or you know so you
know he's hostile to that he never you
never really I would say in his works as
far as I can tell has any moments where
he considers it a genuine possibility
for himself although his absurdist
ethics in mythos if Issus doesn't
actually rule it out completely
depending on how we interpret it right
and there are some figures in his works
that are Christians that he has a rather
you know if not totally endorsing their
points of view at least you know not
entirely hostile viewpoint on because
come lose a complex thinker
uh chilka ever got the chance to read
some Du Bois I've had the chance to
teach Dubois Dubois is how it's supposed
to be pronounced but you know from a
French background that's it's it's
really tough not to read it that way
yeah I've read him I you know I took
African American African a philosophy
when I was at Fayetteville State
University and I read him some in
graduate school as well
enjoyed it you know let Romeo you often
you see more often to say I don't buy
into X metaphysics into whose
metaphysics you buy into most I don't
know that I actually say I don't buy
into X metaphysics but whose metaphysics
do I buy into the most you know I'm an
eclectic so I don't really have a a
single one that I you know I get you
know I suppose if you want to say you
know something like that it would
probably be somebody like you know mock
Schuyler Maurice blown down right where
persons are absolutely central and
values exist you know but you know I'd
bring together all these other things
I'm willing and willing to be quite
Catholic in the lowercase C about my
metaphysics as I am with my epistemology
or my ethics escape cope mechanism have
you seen any new movies that are
philosophically interesting
I haven't yet because I haven't watched
any I didn't watch a lot of movies
lately TV shows I could say yes there's
an Australian TV show about a hit man
called mint mystery in between my wife
is whispering that to me and the
background that we've been watching that
is got a lot of really interesting not
just moral dilemmas because I think that
a lot of people think that writing a
good show is it should have some moral
dilemmas
that there's got to be like genuine
pathos of character to make the moral
dilemmas stick and it's got to be filmed
right - and I'm seeing that we've only
seen like the first maybe four or five
episodes of it but I'm really really
impressed with it so far
obviously in Westworld you know I'm
looking forward to the next season
coming out like watching Rick and Morty
with my kids we get into some good
discussion about things we even play the
board games based on it what else TV
shows you know that superhero on the
boys that was that was pretty decent I'm
kind of looking forward to seeing where
they go with that the big challenge is
like the writers not screwing it up it's
so easy to screw up movies and and TV
shows in the way that you write it and
who the pro you know the antagonists are
and how things develop and there's quite
a few TV shows I'll mention as well that
I'm really disappointed that they they
didn't get continued oh you know another
one that we did did watch it's been a
while since since we've seen it that was
really quite good - was the expanse
I understand it's based on some books
that all eventually read but it also
really strikes me as being whoever wrote
these books is really indebted to see CJ
chera great science fiction author whose
works I really enjoy as well yeah I mean
I also like you know a lot of funny TV
shows like Always Sunny I don't know we
can say that I mean they never really
learned anything and if they do develop
it but yeah alright John Samuel what are
your thoughts on Thomas Reed's principle
of common sense heaven read read since
grad school so I don't have anything to
say about it
Antigua any preliminary reading required
to read the Divine Comedy or can I dive
right into it you can dive right into
anything just you know expect that
sometimes it's gonna be rather
challenging so with the Divine Comedy
you probably want some useful commentary
who provides that I don't know because
you know again I as I say so often I
don't spend much time on secondary lit
because you know I'm usually reading
primary texts and even when I'm teaching
them I'm teaching my students so I don't
need to give them secondary lit other
than maybe some encyclopedia entries
because I'm gonna talk about what's
going on in it so Molesey doodles or you
read gregory palamas what are your
thoughts on Orthodox philosophy and
theology I haven't read palamas Orthodox
theology and philosophy there's a lot of
Orthodox thinkers that I do draw up on
you know that I read but if you're
talking about like contemporary stuff I
don't I don't really bother with it I
don't read much theology anyway quite
frankly you know I don't read much
Catholic theology or Protestant theology
these days now that I'm not teaching
religious studies classes I will say
this the Orthodox definitely had like a
beef with the Ansem it's usually based
on bad glosses and not actually reading
in David Bentley Hart is a great piece
on why that's the case
so yeah all right L ed dry leaden if
solipsism were true in that case would
that make you God well it might make you
you got or somebody else right means
that there's only one one ultimate being
and everything else is sort of a figment
of that so you know maybe maybe we'd all
be just figments of somebody's vast
imagination movies clips and so on
suggest me English language encyclopedia
not even sure what tricks there titus
andronicus do you think Aristotle's work
should be labeled as sexist I mean you
can if you want he says some really dumb
things about women I certainly wouldn't
dueces work to being sexist because his
work actually contains stuff within it
that you can use for combating the the
obvious sexism in his work i mean if you
had aristotle here today and he were to
talk with a bunch of typical college
students he'd probably be more impressed
with you know many of the female college
students that he would with the male
ones
and then he'd revise his ideas because
he was a smart guy linden asks do I have
any time for the extended mind idea and
embodied cognition no not really because
you know I haven't read enough of that
literature to even really have an
opinion on it so I mean if it's along
the lines of like Meryl Aponte noting in
the phenomenology that you know the the
blind person senses through the cane not
you know simply by means of the cane
then sure I'm cool with that but I don't
know exactly how far the minds supposed
to extend I'm Akita to what extent is
handle driven by herders understanding
of spirits I don't know I haven't read
much hurt her so I'm gonna kiss a really
interesting question who is your least
favorite philosopher least favored like
the one I think is the worst that's a
tough one because you know I can usually
find something worthwhile in anybody it
would need to be somebody who's like
wrong most of the time and just not not
you know worth reading at all we're like
just reading them makes you need to like
take a shower afterwards I don't know I
don't know I'm gonna say this
so what pops in my head maybe because of
that needing to take a shower is is when
I read Tucson I was super disappointed
because I think I you know I read him in
high school
because everyone said are so you know so
terrible so so dirty right and
pornography and Assad was really just
boring as hell even later when I read it
in French in graduate school pretty
boring just like let's it's sort of like
a person basically taking a bunch of
Barbie dolls with anatomically correct
parts and saying let's put them together
this way now let's put them together
this way having with each other you know
and after a while you're like this this
mechanics is really dull his philosophy
parts are you know more interesting but
they're very predictable you know like
as soon as you know that they're bad
guys you had a good idea what they're
gonna say so yeah that might be part of
it uh John cowboy who if anyone involved
Kierkegaard or contemporized him sart's
Heidegger my editor draws you know quite
a bit uh um yah Spurs the whole
existentialist tradition and in many
respects to some it depends on who
you're reading of course I mean if some
of them didn't because they they didn't
like Kierkegaard but there's plenty of
Kierkegaard scholars out there in the
present as a matter of fact there's even
a book that was devoted to contemporary
Kierkegaard Ian's arguing why Alistair
McIntyre had Kierkegaard wrong and after
virtue that was done by the Kierkegaard
Society of America or international
grant Society I don't really remember
who so there's plenty of people out
there still working with Kierkegaard on
draga Mito any thoughts on Byung chul
Han no because I don't I don't even know
who that is so um let's see else we've
got some other people just jumped in a
lot of questions here including some
that looks like they got flag maybe
they're swearing or something like that
YouTube will you know get you for that
Tawadros what's the relation between
philosophy and history philosophy
well if you ask me they're the inner to
penetrate each other if you ask an
analytic you know there's real
philosophy then there's history of
philosophy but that's because they don't
know any usually I don't know any actual
history philosophy and they use it just
as sort of a place to put the stuff that
they don't think is making a
contemporary contribution but a lot of
times they're like repeating the past I
tend to think that you know you develop
as a philosopher in part through
engagement with other philosophers and
why would you deprive yourself of the
opportunity to study some of the great
works of the past who are you know quite
brilliant and can give you some distance
and perspective on our own era now
there's different ways of doing history
of philosophy like you know one of my
one of my colleagues says I'm basically
interested in figuring out where the
ideas of the person came from and you
know when I hear that I'm like well
that's that's fun you know that's good
intellectual detective work that doesn't
tell you really much about like the
totality of their ideas or whether
they're applicable of the present or
have any import you know more broadly
speaking but you know that's the way
some people do history of philosophy so
it really depends on what you what you
mean by that elite ed drillin does
Cartesian philosophy align more with
Hindu doctrines or Buddhist doctrines
neither
I mean Hindu doctrines what do you mean
Hinduism is like a whole umbrella for a
whole bunch of different religions and
ideas you can't be relying on some sort
of like encyclopedia and tree and
Hinduism for what Hindu doctrines would
be whose doctrines right and you can say
the same thing about Buddhism I mean
which particular school all right and I
don't I don't find this this sort of
comparative work on the hats
grand-scale particularly interesting or
helpful
Michael asked you had advice for someone
practicing living in accordance with
anger for anger with nature for anger
management but their family members let
their anger get the better of them and
don't support me control online well
yeah don't expect your family members to
support yous step one and if you know
part of it so if you're referencing this
living in accordance with nature you're
probably thinking in terms of stoicism
and the first lesson for anybody who's
practicing stoicism that often has to be
learned over time very difficult the
rest of the world are not Stoics because
you choose to be a stoic so or practice
stoicism so you'd you know you better
like realize early on that they're
probably you know and if you go around
as is why epictetus says don't tell
people that you're studying philosophy
you go around and you're like yeah I'm
doing this new thing please support me
and they're a bunch of pricks they're
gonna like push your buttons even more
right so I wouldn't do that I would you
know think about here's one thing think
about Epictetus is dis not just courses
and karidian for everything that you do
ask yourself what am I actually trying
to do here am I am I trying to get this
out of the situation this out of the
situation or am I willing to let those
things go so that I can keep my prior
ASIS in accordance with nature my
Faculty of choice and with anger if you
have anger problems like I do you are
going to lose control of your temper at
times and then the question is well what
do you do afterwards you know beat
yourself up over it or pick yourself up
and start again the more than you do it
the the longer time will pass in between
lapses and you know eventually you'll
develop more and more control over it I
did you know an entire workshop you can
watch the video for
for that I did an entire workshop that
stoic on 2016 on stoic techniques for
dealing with anger so that might be
helpful for you
Linden Bailey do you think the seeds of
the concept of ideologies are there and
Hegel's work whose concept of ideologies
is the question right there's multiple
ideas about what ideology constitutes
you mean Marxist notion of middie ology
where it's tied in with like it's a
misrepresentation of the world that also
perpetuates that yeah I guess you could
say that's there in each of those you
know particularly in the phenomenology
and each of those like dialectical
stages the dis Dalton I guess you could
say that that's you know each one of
them represents a kind of etiology in a
way I already answered one about Jung so
I'm the skip over is EXO's question
Andrew wife's what is my favorite 80s
one-hit wonder song that's a good one
one-hit wonder who's a who's a good
one-hit wonder
I mean Golden Earring had more than
radar love right let me look him up
because that was a that was a big one
that got played a lot I mean there
aren't that many bands whose one-hit
wonder and oh they had Twilight Zone
yeah so obviously they're not a one-hit
wonder
oh they're Dutch I don't know that no
I'd have to add that that's a tough one
I'd have to think about that let's see
here William
any thoughts on a good way for a
secondary English language arts teacher
to include philosophy in their classes
as a college prof are there any
philosophers you wish secondary students
knew before college those are good
questions yeah so if you think about
like core areas of philosophy there's a
lot of ways you could work in secondary
English Language Arts okay so you can
think in terms of like arguments and
presentation and what philosophers you
could use some of their stuff is raw
material and you could also use some of
the things that they say about you know
argumentation or bias or things like
that I mean think about like Bacon's for
idols right that could easily be turned
into a little module that you would you
would teach in class and then use to to
discuss things and talk about
contemporary examples are there any
philosophers that they they should know
but by the time that they get to college
I don't think there's any that you know
would be like the one that you need to
know just introducing them to the idea
that there's this whole discipline of
philosophy out there and that they're
typically not getting it in their K
through 12 education and that it's worth
studying and you know not also stress to
them in other civilized places right all
across the world people are studying
this in K through 12 so it's part you
know studying philosophy if you're not
just going like a technical school route
for the places that differentiate
between the sort of a technical path and
an academic path they usually will have
some philosophy in high school sometimes
even in middle school so then I think
that would be you know quite good to get
across to them alright Joe yes I just
stumbled across your channel I find it
very interesting and very detailed I'm
not a philosophy major nor have I read
anything to do with it before where do
you suggest I start always start with
Plato you know
and then go on wherever you want from
there I've got a whole series of videos
that I keep adding to each month
although I didn't make it this last
month of self-directed study in
philosophy focused on different thinkers
movements so you can you can take a look
at that
Dakota why is Hegel and German idealism
in general looked down on by so many
Catholics it's not post Catholics don't
know anything about philosophy period I
don't know where you're getting this
from I mean most most most Catholics
like most Protestants like most Orthodox
like most people and in most religions
don't know anything about intellectual
life sucks it's always been kind of an
elite thing oftentimes they'll get like
a little smattering of it in education
but it totally depends on who's who's
leading it I mean if you mean Catholic
do you mean Catholic thinkers look down
on Hegel and German idealism some do
some doubts you know there was even the
too big in school right who was using
Hegel so I'm not sure where that that's
coming from lolly for a favorite
contemporary novel I don't know probably
I imagine it'd probably be well I guess
you know dick is contemporary right and
my favorite novel by philip k dick is
Scanner Darkly so I guess that would be
it Lennie penny do it did I read any
psychology I read a lot of psychology
psychology came out of philosophy
I've actually published work on Jacques
Lacan so yes I I read a little
psychology Wolsey doodles thoughts on
Crick Keys naming and necessity it's
okay you know if you're into that sort
of thing it's to work in analytic
philosophy
our old one what about a series of
philosophy of rock or metal similar to
the world of speculative fiction I know
you like those genres so worlds of
speculative fiction is a talk series
that's hosted by a local library where I
and the other participants read books by
a particular author pertaining to a
particular narrative universe ahead of
time and then discuss it in the session
I'm not quite sure how I would translate
that to rock or metal right and it would
be absolutely impossible to include
excerpts on YouTube that wouldn't get me
copyright flagged so I'm not sure how
that would work either but you know I do
have I haven't contributed to it for a
long time but I do have when I when I
have the time my heavy metal philosopher
blog and I might shoot some videos for
it down the line but it would be you
know it would be a long time all right
we're now in the I'm gonna jump around
and take stuff that looks particularly
interesting
so we'll see what we've got I make sure
you scroll down a bit and grab some
stuff from down below all right
carnal delusion what's the ideal age to
start philosophy what age did you gain
exposure to philosophical works would
you have preferred to begun earlier no
I'm cool with you know where I am I I
didn't gain exposure to philosophical
works early on but I was fortunate and
that I had quite a few people in my life
who you know they were thinkers my dad
my mom some of my other relatives I had
a few good teachers here and there I
actually did a video a while back on
teachers who had been very influential
on me
and you know the first actual philosophy
book that I encountered was camuto's
mythos synthesis as I mentioned I
probably understood maybe a tenth of
what I was reading you know and then I
you know I was quite interested in world
religions and so I did you know quite a
bit of reading from the local library
and books that I could get about
different you know made major world
religions primarily you know Buddhism
and Hinduism in my my teens you know
I've read I read books like zen and the
art of motorcycle maintenance that
people suggested to me but didn't find
them all that compelling there was
really a lot of things - about you know
games and stuff that is sort of like I'm
on the border of philosophy and and the
notion of game when I was in high school
- and then you know I went in the army
and I remember buying a some cheap like
you know summary and philosophy book
that was interesting in parts and boring
in other parts but we were always
talking about stuff you know so now is
there an ideal age to begin no there
isn't
it really depends on the person like you
know my kids for example obviously as
somebody who has a stake in philosophy
I'd like to introduce them to that but
sometimes they're interested in
sometimes they're not there now we're
not always interested in the same things
that I am you know and having a sort of
light touch with it means that they'll
come to me when they want to know stuff
rather than seeing it as something that
dad is pushing on them so he'll - Berman
do I see any overlap in Plato's
tripartite soul and the structure of the
human brain is understood by
neuroscience parts of the brain which
can be in conflict with one another no
not really I I'd avoid tryna
make these things line up to neatly I
mean people do that with Freud too you
know
oh the tripartite soul looks just like
Freud's you know in ego super-ego well I
mean the inn and the appetites look kind
of similar but not the rest of it I
wouldn't I wouldn't try to line these
things up you know into a one-to-one
correspondence that way all right
retro gamer October 13th Catholic Saint
John Henry Cardinal Newman whose
canonized right is this positive
ramifications for philosophies in
today's society well for philosophy
that's a tough one not many people read
Newman even in Catholic institutions you
know it's funny - I'm gonna say this
there's a lot of people who think that a
Catholic institution is you know like
what Catholic institutions were like
half a century or an entire century ago
I'm gonna point so Marquette is over
that way right just twelve blocks from
here you can go to a place like
Marquette University and you can take
the intro to or the foundations now
called foundations and philosophy and
foundations and theology and stuff like
that class and you can be part of its
Jesuit mission and have just the the
most superficial contact with the entire
Christian intellectual tradition let
alone you know Catholic let alone Jesuit
traditions and that's really the case at
many Catholic institutions of higher
learning there is not an awful lot of
genuinely Catholic lack going on and
sometimes when there is it's kind of the
moribund
you know neo scholastic stuff like learn
this because it's part of the culture
war kind of kind of nonsense or at the
it's all relevant you know it's all like
you know social justice man sort of that
sort of stuff as well and there's not I
mean there's very few people reading
John
even at places where there's there's a
genuine respect for the Catholic
intellectual tradition so I don't I
don't think it's gonna make much impact
on on American educational institutions
and if it's not gonna make much impact
there I don't see it making a hell of a
lot of impact at the level of parishes
or you know the larger society I mean
it's a cool thing but I mean from where
I set I don't really care about
canonization or stuff like that myself
it it's it's become such a long and
ritualistic process it doesn't doesn't
really mean much to me I mean i-i've
been reading him and since well since
graduate school and I like the guy I
think he's quite interesting in many
respects but I you know I'll read him
whether he's canonized or not it doesn't
add anything by him by him having that
wait maybe there's some people who will
take it more seriously because of that
but you know what are they actually
going to do what are they gonna read I
suppose it's probably a big thing for
Newman centers right those who don't
know on like state school and non
Catholic school campuses they're off in
these places that are called Newman
centers for for Catholic students and
and sometimes they're quite good and
sometimes they're they're not so good
depending on who the staff is and you
know what's going on there sometimes
they offer cool programs and all that so
I bet it'll give them a boost so that's
kind of a cool thing right yeah all
right let's see who else we got here
[Music]
to do here's an interesting comment eric
busi feelings and effects produce
reasoning fallacies but that's also what
allows a human judgement able of empathy
artificial intelligence seems the
Plato's dream of rational governments
Gary mill well Plato doesn't think that
there would be a rational government
that didn't hand feelings as a matter of
fact when you read the Republic take a
look at book nine the rational part has
desires and pleasures of its own so it's
not as if it's like cold calculating
that's all there is to it and the human
beings who are guardians are not all
rational part they have a proper
ordering of their highly developed
rational part two they're also highly
developed through mitotic part so
they're also well developed properly
developed appetite of part right
artificial intelligence would be
something very different from that and
you're right
the emotions and effects they often get
us in trouble sometimes even hijack
rationality but they are also quite
important and so you know when we look
at thinkers like Plato and the entire
platonic tradition or Aristotle or the
Stoics the Stoics aren't for a totally
detached cool calm rationality that has
no effects whatsoever
there's there's an attempt to have an
integration of effect and an intellect
so yeah all right um let's see who else
we got here but a food Henry asked do I
consider Iran to be a real philosopher
it depends on what we mean by real if if
we're setting the bar pretty low yeah I
mean she had training
and she wrote books that our philosophy
they're recognizable as such if we're
being sort of objective about this not
Objectivist but objective about this
they're not particularly good philosophy
her history of philosophy is terrible
you know the whole world's basically
divided in this Manichaean way and to
like you know the good and peer assists
and the evil idealists and you know a
collectivists and all this this sort of
thing and it's just nonsense you know
and her her take on aristotle is not a
good reconstruction of Aristotle's own
thought she has you know bizarre things
to say about Conte and Nietzsche and
people like that and you know she you
know she is espousing a coherent
philosophy we shouldn't we shouldn't
dismiss it we should actually engage it
that's why I teach her in my ethics
classes so that people have a good
representative of what egoism really
looks like and then we say is this
sufficient is this where we want to be
and then we move on past that I think
where a lot of her fans are really
problematic isn't that they think that
what she's doing is actually good
philosophy and they don't then read
other stuff unfortunately all right let
me jump around some more here cuttlefish
is the gulf between continental and
analytic philosophy and other schools
like process and pragmatism a problem is
there a hope of bridging it it's always
bridged I mean there's people who've
been doing that for a long time paul
ricoeur and you're gonna have a moss on
the continental side well yeah
deliberately engaged analytic
philosophers of their own time
John wisdom was a analytic philosopher
who you know read psychoanalytic
literature and existentialist stuff and
engaged it there's always people and
doing boundary crossing like that robert
Branum right now is a prime example of
somebody who starts out as an analytic
and you know is doing work on German
idealism and now is really more of a
historic good historian and philosophy
than an analytic philosopher because he
actually reads the texts and thinks
about them so you know there's there's
always the possibility of going beyond
it I think part of the problem is that
it's not just that there's like analytic
philosophy continental philosophy than
whatever else we want to have it's like
analytic philosophy is thinking about it
as like having its own little weird
kingdoms inside of it where people never
venture out of that it'd be sort of like
saying you know can people ever get from
Chicago to Milwaukee yeah they do it all
the time there's even like just blocks
from here the Amtrak where you can take
the train or the bus down to do that but
there are people who only live in their
own little neighborhood in Chicago or in
Milwaukee and rarely ventured forth and
obviously those people they don't even
know their own City let alone the other
city and I think there's there's lots of
people like that in continental and
analytic philosophy lots of people say
my man doing continental philosophy or
like cool what do you think about you
know Maurice merleau-ponty
oh we never read him oh really
that's too bad how about mock sailor
bought haven't read him either oh okay
how about on read big song who's that Oh
didn't Deleuze write about him
yeah Deleuze wrote about him but you
could actually read his own you could
read his books you know just to check
them out on your own so like you know
what he's saying there's people like
that in continental philosophy and
there's people like that in analytic
philosophy too so all right um let's see
what else we got here
Plato's Republic does Nietzsche's
philosophy pair up to Nazi ideology in
any way or was his writing completely
reworked enough by a sister to line up
with the ideology why so extreme why not
you know a little of both I mean as
Chomsky pointed out recently when asked
about Peters
you look close enough and you'll find
some things where Chomsky and Hitler
have some things in common right so the
better way to frame this is is
Nietzsche's philosophy substantively
aligned with with what the Nazis did
with things and the answer is no except
in you know in a generic sense where the
Nazis could be a stand-in for any sort
of like might makes might makes right
under the proper circumstances velocity
right but then it loses distinctive not
zenus Nietzsche thought that that you
know sort of the sort of pan-germanism
and anti-semitism of his time was a sign
of bad character and he criticized both
pretty extensively his his sister of
course was a very committed anti-semite
and you know did did rework his his
stuff but the Nazis weren't relying
primarily on Nietzsche I mean they they
had their own philosophers and they
weren't even really relying on Heidegger
I don't think most of them understood
hide frankly you know if you actually
read their literature it's it's not like
for the most part it's not very
high-level stuff you know it's stuff
that's designed to like I have a certain
point of view that you can you can use
to mobilize the masses
Nietzsche stuff to mobilize the masses
with right the only the only society in
which I really see that sort of thing
happening is like science fiction
societies like in Andromeda if any of
University of that TV show right there's
there's a Nietzsche and character T or
something or other and there's like a
whole new chiyan race but that's that's
like way in the future right and it's
actually interesting because they they
tie together Nietzsche and i'm rendered
that all right
revisionist show what are your thoughts
on air theory and moral anti-realism how
would you refute these two views from
the lens of virtue ethics you know how
would you refute that this or like you
know debate me bro kind of mentality i
don't think that you do refute points of
view like that especially isms i think
that you you look to see what a life
like that would would look like and then
you see where it's gaps are and you
start pointing out well maybe you want a
little aristotle here or some stoicism
here or some you know MacIntyre
something like that to actually live a
in life that was gonna work for you but
it's very rare that people like get you
know some sort of critique or argument
and then they're like holy [ __ ]
I was totally wrong now I'm gonna change
my position era theory I don't know
enough about it to really say much moral
anti-realism it depends on what you mean
I mean that's one of those things where
people are kind of like all over the map
anytime you get an ism it's tempting
there's this problem of what we call
metonymy right metonymy is is a literary
device strictly speaking we're a part
substitutes for the whole or the whole
substitutes for the part or a part
substitutes for a part so whose moral
anti-realism is it this person's view of
it in that case that being blown up to
be it in in general you know so we got
it we got to specify this a little bit
but I think that you know the way that
virtue ethics works a lot of people act
as if like you're gonna lay it out in
terms of axioms and make a bunch of
arguments and then people go oh yeah
yeah I see you know and so they'll talk
about this argument and that argument
it really works by a dialectic between
living a wife and developing you know
some sort sense and you know moral
consciousness and where you've been
wrong and and how you can get things
better this is exactly what McIntyre
says and after virtue and in his other
works you know
so does Eve Simone by the way to French
Catholic thinker who has some very
interesting things to say about virtue
part of the you know you could call it
the you know nouvelle theology movement
so alright we got about 10 minutes left
let's take some others Emin on which
philosopher from the post structuralism
should I read first to get the basic
ideas of this movement there are no
basic ideas of this movement there is no
movement there are at least five of them
and I'm confused post structuralism is a
label that's applied meaning after
structuralism right they're all over the
map you know if you want to read
Foucault well you probably need to read
some Nietzsche first and because
Foucault says that nature was
instrumental in his thinking and then
also read some structuralist stuff if
you want to understand what
post-structuralist is then you need to
read some structuralism so read - so
sirs course on general linguistics and
read some AJ dramas and read some Lettie
Strauss in his Anthropology right and
that might get you going
if your goal is to understand Toulouse
well then maybe you know the loses is
actually post-structuralist
then you need to read some of the people
that Deleuze is referencing right it's
not going to make much sense to read
aunty Oedipus without knowing a good bit
of Freud and not just Freud per se but
Freud is interpreted by the French
psychoanalytic establishment all the
time that that they're reacting against
there isn't any like easy way in with
with that stuff so yeah alright let's
see what else we got here that I might
successfully grab do do
[Music]
Jason hommes do you like black or
death-metal not much not really
interested in most of the genres in a
later metal except for doom and power
and yeah a little bit a little some
contemporary thrash I guess definitely
interested in the new wave of
traditional heavy metal okay but I'm not
into a lot of the genre stuff let's see
here
well here's a good one from John Ortiz
should one get a PhD in philosophy from
a low tier if one cannot get into a top
two your university or should you not
get a PhD at all in philosophy so if you
want to teach which is really the main
reason to get a PhD in philosophy I
think unless you're independently
wealthy you probably want to go through
this pipe ear and institution as you can
not because it actually deserves to be a
high tier institution not because the
education you'll get there is actually
better but because of the way that this
BS job stuff works people care about
prestige that's all there is to it the
upper tier graduates bogart most of the
available jobs and that's been going on
for several generations and that's just
the way the game is played so you know
if you if you want to do something else
with it you know then maybe it doesn't
really matter where you go to although
you're gonna find that people are really
into prestige anywhere you go there's
ways around that you can publish a lot
you can form important contacts you know
but unfortunately pedigree matters
shouldn't but it does
alright HTA HD had heard some mentions
of Heidegger being an existentialist
which part of his philosophy caused this
association the very fact that in being
in time Heidegger uses the word
existential right
over and over and over and over again
the only reason why there's anybody
disassociating heidegger from
existentialism is because of Sartre and
his wish his drive to try to control the
existentialist movement by trying to
define it in such a way that made him be
at the top and others below Heidegger
after reading Sartre stuff said you can
keep the term I'm I'm gonna you know
sort of divorce myself from any sort of
humanistic thing that you have going on
gabriella Marcel also who by the way is
the first person to use the term
existentialism in French Gabriela Marcel
abandons the the term existentialist and
prefers after a certain point to call
himself a Christian Socratic but this is
really more of a PR stunt bye-bye Sartre
that got taken to be sort of a doctrinal
thing by by english-language writers
than anything else hi - here is an
existentialist in you know the important
respects labaki what do I think about
nationalism and ethno-nationalism should
countries or groups of people have
self-determination two different
questions there you can have
self-determination without having
ethno-nationalism I think that
ethno-nationalism is in most cases of
virulent form of ideology that we've
seen many times before people make all
sorts of you know arguments for how it's
going to be different this time and I
don't buy it you know so that's probably
enough about that let's see oh I
answered what about decide in here let's
see oh here's a good one
mr. big weak knee to what degree can we
hold people accountable for lacking care
Virtue's I'm sorry this is so broad
that's a great question
some people we can hold less responsible
you know so think about people who
suffer terrible abuse and it could be a
you know like actual physical abuse
sexual abuse emotional abuse could be
neglect of some types it's often gonna
be coupled with you know not just like
suffering those things but being given
bad role models and mistaken
understandings of the world and what
people are like in it it's it's like a
whole package that you get obviously
they're gonna have they're gonna be way
more at a disadvantage than somebody who
just grows up in American consumer
society in general but has you know a
fairly high degree of autonomy right
we're not going to hold them to the same
standards but here's where I think
Aristotle's distinction between theory
Oh taste or brutality and vice which he
goes back and forth sometimes using
different terms road you know weakness
you know or kochia
badness right I think this is useful so
the vicious person is morally worse than
the person who's been so damaged that
they the higher part is is you know sort
of out of commission for the time being
at least but this is more terrifying
Aristotle says so there's a different
kind of badness to it and you know when
we're offered opportunities for
developing virtue and we may you know
I'll write reject them or we may sort of
appropriate them in ways you think about
people who like want to acquire virtues
like they want to get merit badges for
their Boy Scout or Girl Scout thing
things they can check off right they're
not really becoming virtuous
they're in it for the wrong reason
sometimes out of a sort of desperation
to like you know be able to think of
themselves is a good person sometimes
because they want to hold it over others
all of these are things that stand in
the way of virtue and and I think we you
know there's no like blanket thing that
we can say like ordering them into like
a hierarchy well this is worse this is
better area that sort of thing but we
can apply them to particular cases and
we can talk about types I think with
that so you know the answer is in some
cases we can't hold people responsible
at all because they were there in
conditions where it's just not going to
be feasible to expect them to develop
virtue if it does happen it happens
through something like divine grace or
you know some total perfect coincidence
of events that take their brokenness and
screwed up in this and like give exactly
what they need at the time that's pretty
rare but everybody else bears you know
scaled levels of responsibility the
other thing I'll say about this too is
as you progress towards virtue you also
become more conscious of how screwed up
you are you know what what more needs to
be done there's a lot of things that you
can't actually see that you need to work
on until you've established enough of a
foundation and enough freedom to be able
to take them on so yeah that that's
actually a good thing to close on so I
didn't get to everybody's questions but
I never do we'll do this again at the
beginning of next month I'm gonna try to
do some philosophy pop-ups this month
now that I'm not quite as busy I'm still
super busy but not quite as busy and
we've got some other events coming up
throughout the month as well including
another video premiere that will be
doing on the self directed study in
philosophy
once I get that video shot and yeah
hopefully I'll see some of you and some
other events and those whose questions I
didn't get to maybe hold on to them for
for next time and I'll try to get to
them then we all these things are always
announced ahead of time both in my
social media and on my calendar so
alright I hope everybody has a good
wherever you are
evening morning day middle of the night
and I'll see you later up